we turn now to our special series school
matters we're looking at how the
pandemic is affecting
students education school districts
nationwide say two to three times more
students
are failing classes this year usa today
recently spoke with students about the
challenges they face
because of remote learning i feel like
this online learning is really just
affecting my grades
and i'm really just forget about the
grades not learning as much as i
normally would on a normal year
and i feel that it's so important to get
education
and when it's so hard to get it and
learn through this screen it really
makes it difficult
it almost feels like i'm learning
material and just like taking a bunch of
notes and then
you know taking these multiple choice
quizzes and then the second i'm done
with that quiz or test
the information just like it just slips
off my mind so i feel like
i'm not really making any progress
we're joined now by sal khan founder of
the khan academy the nonprofit
organization offers free
educational lessons online sal good
morning
uh thanks for being with us because this
is this has been a really tough year
for both students and their teachers
who both sides are struggling i think to
get through this
what do you how can teachers at this
point help students as
we said so many of them have had a
really tough time keeping up
yeah at this point it's it's all about
engagement you know the stories we just
heard
those students were having trouble
feeling connected we know there's
multiple layers of stress in the world
right now covet being the top one the
economy
there's a lot else going on and then on
top of that students are expected to
kind of stay engaged while they're
learning primarily in these cases
through a screen
and so there's a couple of things
teachers and they're doing their best
job it's a hard thing for teachers as
well
but as much as possible pull them out of
the screen make the classes interactive
give time for kids to interact with each
other
put them into these virtual breakout
sessions realize that
the screen right now is students main
way to connect with other people
socially so use that class time use a
little bit of it
to also get some social connection
because that's more likely to drive
students to real connection
and then when students are failing which
they're starting to do
disproportionately
we need to give them extra chances it
can't be you got to see a d and f
on a test right now and that's your
final grade on your transcript when we
get back to school you have to have a
a method to remake it you take it sal do
you think school should even recon
reconsider giving grades at all this
year
well i don't think there's anything
wrong with grades per se it's always
valuable to know where you are what i
think schools really need to make sure
and you know this is something we've
always believed at khan academy
even before covid is if you got a c or a
d or an f
that shouldn't be your final grade
because then that gap persists and it
becomes harder to learn more advanced
things this was true even before covid
now we know the situation is happening
to even more students
and when you get that c or d or f it
hits your self-esteem
there's there's a lot of evidence that
it lowers your rate of graduating
especially if it's in a core class
and there's all these other stressors
around so you should always have the
chance especially given the
circumstances we're in right now
that when we get back to normal or even
before we get back to normal you should
have multiple shots at goal to be able
to
improve that to a b or an a hey saul
turner to copeland here
on the subject of getting back to normal
i mean one of the big obstacles to
getting back in the classroom is
teachers understandably
don't feel safe there that being the
case should they get
vaccines that are now available on the
early side rather than
down the line
i'm a big proponent of that because
we've seen over the last several months
that
teaching is such a lynchpin not just for
kids to continue learning and being
engaged like we just saw
but it's a child care issue it's keeping
other families from being able to engage
especially families
that make low lower income and can't
afford other forms of child care
you know my wife's a physician she just
got a letter from her hospital that
they're going to start getting the
vaccine in the next month she works at
the county
hospital i think teachers really need to
be in that first or second wave as well
so how do you deal with with the problem
of of income disparity with with kids i
mean
one thing that's very clear is that for
low income and minority kids
they're less likely to have the
appropriate technology they need for
this and
and they were in many cases they were
already behind and are falling further
behind
and that's a problem it's very hard for
teachers to address
through a computer
yeah and what you just described has
always been a problem
uh that we've always tried to articulate
that we need to help fix
one way to fix it and there's a lot of
layers to this is
more resources to keep student engaged
that's even more important now you know
above and beyond what we just talked
about
how you can run classes more in a more
interactive way
we're seeing some school districts
successfully calling kids
once a day even for 30 seconds even for
a minute making sure that they feel
engaged
but we also know things like the digital
divide are major major issue 20 30 40
of some communities aren't even able to
access right now or
five ten percent of kids even when they
can access are just not like school
districts can't find them right now
and so when we get back to normal
hopefully sooner than later
it really has to be treated like a
disaster recovery we have to figure out
mechanisms to
fill in kids gaps ways for them to do
remediation
obviously khan academy is working on
that i have a
a free this is another non-pro
not-for-profit program called
schoolhouse.world to get free tutoring
we have capacity for several thousands
of kids now
uh so we do whatever we can collectively
to make sure there's ways to fill in
those gaps and they feel supported yeah
that's a good analogy sal it's a
disaster recovery operation
thank you very much sal khan we
appreciate it